.
Als ich aufwuchs, gab es
in meiner Familie keinen Fernseher.
Dass ich zum Fernsehen kam,
war eigentlich ein Irrtum.
Der Fernseher
war für mich eine Art Nanny.
Ich habe sehr viel Zeit - das klingt
ganz schlimm - mit dem TV verbracht.
Am Samstagabend nach dem Bad
gab es immer "Daktari".
Ich arbeitete schon beim TV,
als meine Eltern
ihren ersten Fernseher kauften.
Dieses Darüberleeren ist ein Effekt.
Es sei ungesund, hiess es -
für die Augen.
2 Std. pro Woche
am Mittwochnachmittag.
Ich durfte nicht so lange schauen,
aber es gab ja Schlupflöcher,
wenn man mal allein zu Hause war.
Ich habe als Kind
häufig bei Freunden geschaut,
diese ganzen Serien,
"Lassie", "Fury" etc.
Es kostete ja auch etwas, man musste
sich diesen Apparat anschaffen.
Daher gab es
eine gewisse Zurückhaltung.
Wir alle haben unsere unterschied-
lichen Geschichten mit dem Fernsehen.
Was wir durften und was nicht.
Auch das Fernsehen
hat eine Geschichte: seine eigene.
Die begann vor 70 Jahren - und
vielleicht noch ein bisschen früher.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Um zu verstehen, müssen wir
ein paar Jahre weiter zurückblicken.
Unsere Grosseltern erzählen gerne,
dass damals, Anfang der 50er-Jahre,
alles besser gewesen sei.
Die Frau war dankbar
und lebte am Herd.
Der Herr war erfolgreich
und sass gut gekleidet am Tisch.
Vor der Zeit des Fernsehens war das
der ideale Schweizer Haushalt:
Eine Frau hat zwei Lebensfragen:
Was soll ich anziehen
und was soll ich kochen?
Das Leben war friedlich,
farbig und fernsehfrei.
Die jungen Leute
können sich das kaum vorstellen.
Wie viel Starrheit hier herrschte.
Und Uneinsichtigkeit.
Dabei gab es Tausende von Frauen,
die allein lebten, die arbeiteten.
Oder auch Alleinerziehende.
Das war auch ein Thema,
das unter dem Deckel behalten wurde.
Die Wirtschaft florierte
und die Babys boomten.
Und alles war gut.
Oder fast alles.
So haben sie uns das
immer wieder erzählt.
Die 50er-Jahre
waren für mich geprägt von ...
... vom Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Vom Gedanken,
dass die Schweiz das überlebt hat
dank eigener Kraft.
Die Kraft der Auserwählten.
Die Schweiz ein Paradies auf Erden.
Doch dann kam eben das Fernsehen,
verführerisch und neu.
Und mit der Verführung
kam die Vorahnung,
was passieren würde,
wenn der Mensch nicht widerstünde.
Es gab in der Bevölkerung
und auch bei meinen Eltern
eine gewisse Skepsis
gegenüber diesem neuen Medium.
V.a. hatte man auch ein wenig Angst,
dass die Kinder zu stark
von diesem Medium gefesselt würden.
Angst vor dem Fernsehen
herrschte allenthalben,
auch an den Schaltstellen der Macht.
Vor dem Sendestart
musste der Staatsanwalt
in einem Briefwechsel
mit dem Bundesrat bestätigen,
dass alle Fernsehmitarbeitenden -
damals noch Mitarbeiter -
durch den Geheimdienst
durchleuchtet worden seien,
im Interesse "der inneren
und äusseren Sicherheit".
Als das Fernsehen aufkam,
stand es unter dem Generalverdacht,
ein triviales Medium zu sein,
das es nicht unbedingt brauche.
"Wir haben doch Radio.
Wozu brauchen wir noch Bilder?"
Selbst Lokalpolitiker massten sich
ein Urteil über das neue Medium an.
"Wenn das, was wir sahen,
einigermassen
den normalen Sendungen,
wie sie geplant sind, entspricht,
dann kann man vom Bildungsstandpunkt
aus zunächst nur eines sagen:
barbarisch, Erziehung
zur Oberflächlichkeit."
Den Menschen jedoch schmeckte
diese neue Verführung im Wohnzimmer.
Plötzlich konnten sie
durch einen kleinen Kasten
in die Welt hinausblicken.
Lauberhornrennen 1950:
Hauptprobe unserer Alpinen
für die Weltmeisterschaften.
Fredy Rubi, Wengen in der Abfahrt.
Er wird meisterhaft mit den Tücken
der z.T. vereisten Strecke fertig.
Mein Bruder kam nach Hause
und sagte,
er habe ein Skirennen in einem
Kasten, im Fernsehen, gesehen.
Ich sagte: "Das ist nicht wahr,
das gibt es nicht."
Wir bekamen wirklich Krach.
Er siegt mit 4 Min. und 2,4 Sek.
Und später gab es
die Krönung von Queen Elizabeth.
Die Leute schauten sie
in den Schaufenstern.
My whole life,
whether it be long or short,
shall be devoted to your service.
Der Fernseher wurde rasch
zu einem zentralen Altar.
Die Familien
entwickelten ihre Rituale.
In der Stadt auf jeden Fall
schaute man am Morgen in die Zeitung
und hörte Radio.
Am Mittag hört man Radio
und am Abend sah man fern.
* Gong *
Hier ist die "Tagesschau".
Zunächst die wichtigsten Meldungen.
Ich glaube, es war v.a. auch
die technische Faszination.
Bewegte Bilder
kamen zu einem nach Hause.
Ich kann mich erinnern,
dass meine Grossmutter
Paul Spahn, der damals
die "Tagesschau" präsentierte,
immer persönlich begrüsste.
Friedliche Demonstration
in Westberlin.
10'000 Personen ...
Die Faszination war gross
und wurde immer grösser.
Allein im ersten Jahrzehnt
stieg die Anzahl der TV-Abonnenten
von 30'000 auf 130'000 an.
Und sie erfreuten sich daran,
die Welt in ihren eigenen vier Wänden
zu Besuch zu haben.
* Big-Band-Musik *
# Refrain ...
Gebannt lauschte die Schweiz,
als Lys Assia
den ersten Song Contest gewann,
und erlebte live, wie Deutschland
in Bern ein Fussballwunder schuf.
Damals fanden ja jene,
die gegen das Fernsehen waren,
die Familien gehen dabei drauf,
die würden nur noch
in diesen Kasten schauen.
Am Schluss war es das Gegenteil.
Die Familien hatten ein
gemeinsames Samstagabendprogramm,
und die Gesellschaft
unterhielt sich über diese Themen.
Tatsächlich erhielt das Publikum
mit dem neuen Medium
auch Einblicke
in den weltweiten Schrecken.
Bewegte Bilder
des Algerienkrieges ...
... Rassendiskriminierung
in den USA ...
I have a dream.
... und das Auflehnen dagegen.
Wie damals, als Rosa Parks
ein Zeichen
und sich selbst im Bus dahin setzte,
wo sonst nur Weisse sassen.
Wahrheit und Ungerechtigkeit
mit eigenen Augen zu sehen,
daran musste sich das Publikum
erst gewöhnen.
"Dieses Fernsehen
ist doch schrecklich."
"Es könnte propagandistisch sein,
es könnte die Leute verführen,
es könnte mit diesem starken Bild
einen schlechten Einfluss haben."
Diese Angst gab es
in der Bevölkerung.
* Big-Band-Musik *
Die 60er-Jahre
waren ja das Jahrzehnt,
in dem der konjunkturelle Aufschwung
startete,
Leute konnten sich mehr leisten,
u.a. einen Fernseher.
Die Reihenfolge war etwa:
Waschmaschine, Auto, Fernseher.
Wenn ich mich zurückerinnere, er-
innere ich mich an das Fernsehgerät.
Das war ein Möbel auf vier Beinen.
Und man konnte es zumachen.
Es gab eine hölzerne Klappwand.
Man musste immer aufstehen,
wenn man den Sender wechseln wollte.
Und ich glaube, zu meiner Zeit waren
es zwei Sender, vielleicht drei.
Der Schweizer
und der deutsche Sender.
The president's car
is turning onto Elm Street.
Ich war ein Jahr lang in Kalifornien
im Austausch in der Highschool.
Dort hatte ich
Kontakt mit Fernsehen.
Dort schaute man TV.
Ich hatte auch Auftritte
im Lokalfernsehen
und erzählte über die Schweiz.
Und so wusste ich,
als ich zurückkam - da war ich 18 -
dass Fernsehen interessant ist.
It appears as though
something has happened.
Im Vergleich zu Zeitungen gibt es
mit dem Bild, mit dem Ton ...
Es nimmt einen mehr rein,
es bewegt viel mehr.
Es hat eine Unmittelbarkeit,
die du beim Lesen,
wenn du das verarbeiten musst,
nicht hast.
Das ist z.T. beängstigend, hat
aber auch riesige Chancen eröffnet,
auch beim Publikum.
Es ist klar, dass das Fernsehen
eine grosse
dokumentarische Wirkung hat.
Diese Erfahrung
musste die Bevölkerung machen.
Als sie diese gemacht hatte, war
das Fernsehen sehr schnell populär.
* Feierliche Musik *
(Originalton, Mann) Niemand hat die
Absicht, eine Mauer zu errichten.
Dass Bilder nicht lügen, erlebte die
Welt mit der Staatsgründung der DDR
und dem Bau der Mauer in Berlin.
Meine Eltern sahen auch gerne fern.
Und meine Eltern
waren mit dem Fernseher ...
Bei der Mondlandung bekamen sie
einen Fernseher geschenkt.
Das war auch ein Tor zur Welt.
Mit dem Fernseher konnte man
reisen, entdecken, dazulernen.
Sie sahen gerne fern.
Ignition sequence starts. Two, one,
lift-off! We have a lift-off.
32 minutes past the hour.
Lift-off on Apollo 11.
Ich durfte nicht fernsehen,
das war strikt verboten.
Aus edukativen Gründen mieteten
meine Eltern einen Fernseher,
als die Mondlandung kam.
Die Mondlandung war das Wichtigste.
Da weiss jeder noch, wo er war,
alle haben das geschaut.
That's one small step for man,
one giant leap for mankind.
Beautiful, just beautiful.
Die Mondlandung
war etwas vom Ersten,
und im Showbereich
dann alles, alles.
So.
Die Eroberung des Mondes
und die Geburt der ersten Stars
geschahen am Schweizer Bildschirm
fast gleichzeitig.
Heidi Abel war der erste weibliche
Liebling des TV-Publikums.
... ein dicker Bauch und viel zu
viel Fell für so einen kleinen Hund.
Ihr männliches Pendant
war Mäni Weber.
Seine Popularität
war in der Schweiz so gross,
dass das Fernsehen am 23. August 1968
von seiner Hochzeit
mit Irene Monigatti berichtete.
... die Ehe eingehen?
- Ja.
Es war die Geburtsstunde des People-
Journalismus am Schweizer Fernsehen.
Hören Sie mich gut und deutlich?
- Jawohl.
Mit den ersten
eigenproduzierten Samstagabendshows
fesselte Mäni Weber
in den 60er- und 70er-Jahren
das Publikum an den Bildschirm.
Als Mäni Weber "Dopplet oder nüt"
machte, mussten Vereine ...
Das war so spannend, es war
ja auch eine schlaue Sendung.
Vereine durfte nicht an jenem Abend
ihre Zusammenkünfte machen,
sonst kaum zu wenig Leute.
Mäni Weber war es auch vergönnt,
die erste Samstagabendshow in Farbe
zu präsentieren.
* Applaus *
Guten Abend, liebe Zuschauer.
... ins Restaurant
oder die Metzgerei ...
Assistiert hatten ihm stets
junge Frauen,
deren eigentliche Aufgabe sich
darauf beschränkte, zu schweigen.
Sie wollen aber nicht mal reden?
- Doch, ich will mal reden.
Kaum sind Frauen eine Zeit
am Bildschirm, wollen sie reden.
Hier meldet sich das Studio
Bellerive des Schweizer Fernsehens.
Guten Tag, liebe Zuschauer/-innen.
Wir beginnen unser Programm ...
Das war die Bestimmung der Frau
am Bildschirm:
anzukünden, welch grosse Männer
sogleich über den Weltenlauf
sprechen werden.
...Schriftsteller
und die Tschechoslowakei.
Es sprechen Peter Bichsel,
Friedrich Dürrenmatt,
Max Frisch,
Günter Grass und Kurt Marti.
Ansagerinnen gab es, aber
wenn man alte Sendungen anschaut ...
Es war alles noch Schwarz-Weiss.
Aber das sieht z.T.
grausam grau-schwarz aus,
und alles Männer, gesetzte Männer.
Insofern, so könnte man sagen,
war der Bildschirm
nicht mehr und nicht weniger
als ein Abbild der Gesellschaft -
der Männergesellschaft.
Wir sind der Überzeugung,
dass die Erheblichkeit
des Geschlechtsunterschiedes
nach wie vor gross ist.
Und dass darum der Frau
das Stimm- und Wahlrecht
nicht gegeben werden soll.
Spurenelemente des Denkens,
wie es dieser Aargauer Rechtsanwalt
vertrat,
waren damals offensichtlich
auch am Fernsehen noch nachzuweisen.
Die Verteidigung war,
bei den Nachrichten gehe es
um die ernsten Dinge der Welt.
Das müssen die Männer machen.
Das gehört mit zum ganzen Wandel
des Männer- und Frauenbildes.
Das hat sicher damit zu tun,
dass man die Frauen lange Zeit ...
Das waren lange Zeit die,
die man gerne anschaute
und die etwas Lustiges, vielleicht
Interessantes präsentieren können.
Aber wenn es so richtig
um die Sache geht,
Politik und so,
ist das Männersache.
Sie ist Hausfrau und Mutter eines
Babys, wie alt ist es?- Elf Monate.
Und wer hütet es?
- Es ist bei meiner Schwester.
Solche Fragen müssen bis heute
nur Frauen beantworten.
1971 mit der Einführung
des Frauenstimmrechts
hat sich das
nach und nach gewandelt.
Im Juni 1971 durften Frauen in der
ganzen Schweiz erstmals an die Urne,
nachdem sich die Männer
vier Monate zuvor
für das Frauenstimmrecht
ausgesprochen hatten.
Und sofort war auch am Bildschirm
alles anders.
Frauen hatten in der wichtigsten
Nachrichtensendung, der "Tagesschau",
eine Stimme und ein Gesicht -
möchte man gerne annehmen.
Doch bis dahin
war es noch ein weiter Weg.
Liebe Zuschauer, wir sind hier auf
dem Flughafen Basel-Mühlhausen ...
Helen Issler, die damals noch Helen
Kehl, resp. Fräulein Kehl hiess,
war eine der Wegbereiterinnen
der Gleichberechtigung.
Ich wollte immer
Journalistin werden.
Dann gab es ein Inserat im Radio,
da stand:
"Reportervolontäre gesucht."
Das sagte ich: "Ist da auch
ein Mädchen, eine Frau gemeint?",
und bewarb mich.
Sie erhielt trotz
fehlendem Y-Chromosom die Stelle
und wurde die erste Reporterin
des Magazins "Antenne".
Es gibt eine Anekdote: Ich merkte,
dass ich 50 Fr. weniger verdiente
als ein Kameramann,
der gleich alt war wie ich -
und meine Ausbildung war besser.
Ich ging zu Hans O. Staub,
der damals Informationschef war,
und sagte, das sei ungerecht.
Er sagte zu mir: "Fräulein Kehl,
Sie können doch selber kochen
und selbst Ihre Blusen waschen."
Ein Mann hat viel mehr Ausgaben.
Guten Abend, liebe Zuschauer ...
Dennoch verkündete sie
wenige Jahre später am Bildschirm,
auftoupiert, selbstbewusst
und leicht übereilt
die Gleichberechtigung.
Wir haben ein neues Dekor und die
Gleichberechtigung wurde eingeführt.
Darum bin ich heute
zum ersten Mal hier.
* Gemütliche Klänge *
Spätestens ab den 70er-Jahren
war das Fernsehen nicht mehr
aus dem Alltag wegzudenken.
Es spielte eine Rolle
in der Gesellschaft,
dabei, wie man
miteinander kommunizierte.
Das Fernsehen war
ein wichtiger Faktor für fast alles,
über das gesprochen wurde,
sei es Politik oder Unterhaltung.
# Ich heisse Teleboy
und schwanke hin und her.
Wenn am Samstagabend der "Teleboy"
und sein Schöpfer Kurt Felix
die Nation begrüssten,
sass die vereinte Schweizer Familie
vor dem Fernseher
und gab sich dem sorglosen Leben
in einer sorgenfreien Welt hin.
Dass ein Aufrüstung der Supermächte
stattfand, dass Regenwald abgeholzt,
giftige Werkstoffe in Wohnhäuser
verbaut, der Schah gestürzt,
Politiker ermordet
und Meere mit Öl verpestet wurden,
ging um ein frisch geföhntes Haar
vergessen.
* Applaus *
Ich bin 1968 geboren.
Ich kann mich an den Ölschock
Mitte der 70er-Jahre erinnern.
* Dramatische Musik *
Der Vietnamkrieg berührte mich,
die Bilder dieser
letztlich fliehenden Amerikaner
mit dem Helikopter auf dem Dach.
Das sind spezielle Bilder,
die viele Leute in Erinnerung haben.
Diese Sachen habe ich aus
den 70er-Jahren v.a. mitbekommen,
die haben mich beeindruckt.
Fernsehen ist: Wenn es wirklich
ernst wird, kommt es im Fernsehen.
Das war etwas,
zusammen mit "Aktenzeichen XY",
das wir als Familie immer schauten.
Ich weiss nicht, ob man dachte,
die Kinder müssen das schauen,
damit sie bei niemandem
ins Auto einsteigen.
Für den nächsten Fall sind
die Schweizer Behörden zuständig.
Bitte, Konrad Toenz.
Die Kantonspolizei Aargau
bearbeitet einen Fall,
der hier in der Schweiz
grosses Aufsehen erregt hat.
"Aktenzeichen XY" - ich musste
jeweils im Keller Süssmost holen.
Und zwar nicht im ersten,
sondern im zweiten Keller.
Das war ...
Dort würde man Leichen aufbewahren.
Ich ging ganz alleine in meinen
kurzen Hosen und den Bally-Schuhen
dort runter und war tot,
als ich wieder oben war,
vor lauter Herzrasen.
Ich habe manchmal das Gefühl,
Generationen von Kindern
wurden leicht traumatisiert
von den Nachstellungen
irgendwelcher Gewaltverbrechen,
die man dort zur Prävention zeigte.
Aber "Aktenzeichen XY"
schaute man zusammen mit den Eltern
und man hoffte,
dass einem das nie passiert.
Leichter bekömmlich
und pädagogisch wohl wertvoller
zeigte sich das Schweizer Fernsehen
in den 70er-Jahren
mit dem "Spielhaus".
* Fröhliche Titelmelodie *
Das Signet, die Musik:
"Komm rein, es heisst Spielhaus."
Es gab immer andere Dinge.
Das ist die erste Erinnerung
an ein Kinderprogramm,
das ich schauen durfte.
Komm rein, es gehört dir,
es heisst Spielhaus.
Grüezi miteinander.
Heute erklären wir euch
und spielen etwas übers Flicken.
Kognitiv müssen sie sein
und prosozial.
Das waren zwei Stichworte,
die dann über diese Sendungen
gelegt wurden.
Man sah dann, dass sie
sehr kognitiv und prosozial waren.
Ich bin Franz,
das ist René, er sagt nichts.
Ich sage nichts.
Dieser Satz, das merkten wir bald,
prägte viele Kinder geradezu.
Eltern sagten, wenn sie die Kinder
etwas Unangenehmes fragten,
sagten sie: "Ich sage nichts", oder
"Ich bin René, ich sage nichts."
Andere hielten nichts
von Renés Leitsatz,
sondern übten systematisch Kritik.
Die 70er-Jahre
waren genauso kritisch wie heute,
es gab genauso viel Opposition
wie heute gegen Fernsehen und Radio.
Genauso eine Stimmung wie heute,
man könnte die Gebühren abschaffen.
Man griff damals
noch nicht zu diesem Mittel.
Aber diese fast Hassstimmung gegen
den politischen Teil des Fernsehens
gab es schon damals
und das hat sich nicht verändert.
Ich glaube,
es gab schon immer den Versuch,
dieses Medium
zu instrumentalisieren,
oder zumindest zu disziplinieren,
indem man
unliebsame Berichterstattung
oder unliebsame Themen oder so
verhindern wollte.
Es ist ein Anspruch,
weil es eine Anstalt
des Service public ist,
dass alle darin vorkommen wollen,
dass alle so vorkommen wollen,
wie sie sich selbst sehen.
Und dass alle das Gefühl haben,
wenn es nicht so ist,
drehen sie den Finanzhahn zu.
Zu Beginn der 80er-Jahre
standen die Zeichen auf Rebellion.
* Dynamische Musik *
(Originalton) Wir stehen vermutlich
erst am Anfang.
Die Krankheit heisst
Minikopfhörer-Rekorder-Fieber.
Oder auf Englisch: Walkman.
Erkennungsmerkmal
für eine Generation,
der die Kommunikation
abhandengekommen ist.
Wer wem nicht zuhörte
und wessen Fragen, Ängste,
Bedürfnisse und Rechte
auf der Strecke blieben,
darüber sind Bücher geschrieben
und Bundesordner gefüllt worden.
Tatsache ist: In den 80er-Jahren
begehrte die Jugend auf,
und das wiederum brachte
die Ordnungshüter auf die Idee,
ihre Muskeln zu zeigen.
In Zürich lieferten sich
junge Menschen und die Polizei
richtige Strassenschlachten.
Das Fernsehen
war ein enormer Themensetzer.
Es hat sich etwas verändert.
Und zwar darum,
weil es so viele Kanäle gibt -
es gibt das Internet, Social Media.
Aber als das Fernsehen
noch so dominant war,
als praktisch jede Familie
am Abend dasselbe Programm schaute,
war das am nächsten Tag
Gesprächsstoff.
So, jetzt reicht es.
Grüezi miteinander.
Auf die Gefahr hin, dass die Berner,
die Basler oder die Churer
wieder sagen, das Schweizer
Fernsehen sei ein Zürcher Fernsehen,
erzähle ich etwas
von den Zürcher Krawallen -
oder soll ich sagen Zürcher Unruhen?
Die Krawalle sind vorbei,
aber die Unruhe ist noch da.
Während vier Jahren
hatte ich einmal im Monat,
als "Aktenzeichen XY" kam,
von 20.00-20.15 Uhr
eine satirische Sendung.
Heute würde man sagen
ein satirisches Format.
Man kommt an
ein wirklich grosses Publikum ran,
das nie einen Fuss
z.B. in ein Theater setzen würde.
Das gibt entsprechende Reaktionen.
Das war z.T. sehr heftig,
das ging bis zu Morddrohungen.
Für Gesprächsstoff sorgte in jener
Zeit auch die Sendung "Karussell".
* Schaukelnde Schlussklänge *
Das "Karussell" verstand sich
als Avantgarde des Fernsehens.
Es wurde viel experimentiert
und es wurden viele Dinge gemacht,
die später Schule machten.
Z.B. die grossen Live-Reportagen,
wie der "Schwanensee" auf zwei
Kanälen hinter und vor der Bühne.
Ich bestritt als Reporter/Moderator
die Lauberhornabfahrt.
Pirmin Zurbriggen beurteilte mich.
Diese Sachen kannte man
damals nicht im Fernsehen,
sie waren neu und speziell.
Auch im Februar 1980 erlebte das
Publikum etwas noch nie Dagewesenes:
Fast auf den Tag genau neun Jahre,
also 108 Monate,
nach Annahme des Frauenstimmrechts
fand das Schweizer Fernsehen
eine weibliche Stimme
für die "Tagesschau".
Fast kein Bett mehr frei
in unseren Wintersportorten.
Eine Umfrage der "Tagesschau".
Ich vermute, dass wir
die erste "Tagesschau"-Moderatorin
vor der ersten Bundesrätin hatten.
Das ist mein Tipp. Ist das so?
(Vetsch) Ja, gut.
Das zeigt, wie lange Dinge dauern.
Ich gehöre auch
zu 50 % der Bevölkerung.
Es ist wichtig, gerade im Fernsehen,
dass es Identifikationsfiguren gibt.
Role Models.
Es ist so wichtig,
dass man sich daran gewöhnt.
Das ist die Gesellschaft
in der Schweiz.
Ansonsten hatten die 80er-Jahre
mit all ihren Katastrophen,
Zwischenfällen
und der schlechten Musik
das Potenzial,
uns die Laune zu verderben.
Daran konnte auch die Erfindung
des Natels nur wenig ändern.
* Klingelton *
Ja, Grüezi, Frau Keller.
Die Wissenschaft
versichert uns glaubhaft,
dass Präservative vorläufig
das einzig wirksame Mittel sind,
um sich vor einer Ansteckung
mit dem Aidsvirus zu schützen.
Dieses kleine Ding kann also
über Leben und Tod entscheiden,
daran ändern weder erotische
noch ästhetische
oder moralische Bedenken etwas.
Als hätte der Kalte Krieg nicht
schon für genügend Schauder gesorgt,
erreichte uns am 28. April 1986 aus
dem damals sowjetischen Tschernobyl
die Meldung über eine nukleare
Katastrophe in einem Kernkraftwerk.
(Issler) Radioaktivität
auch in der Schweiz.
Nach der Atomkatastrophe
von Tschernobyl
gibt es fast nur noch
ein Gesprächsthema.
Wie viele gefährliche Stoffe
sind zu uns gekommen?
Darf man unsere Milch noch trinken?
Kann man das Gemüse noch essen?
Das sind nur zwei der Fragen,
die wir uns alle stellen.
Deshalb macht das Fernsehen DRS
ein Sonderprogramm.
Experten beantworten morgen zwischen
18 und 23 Uhr Ihre Fragen im Studio.
Unsere wichtigsten Sendungen
im "Schweiz aktuell" damals
drehten sich um Schweizerhalle
oder Tschernobyl.
Dort hatten wir die Rolle eines ...
... wie einen Bezug
zu den Zuschauern.
Die Behörden sagten in beiden Fällen
erst, es sei nichts passiert.
Frei nach Franz Hohler. Dann riefen
die Leute an und fragten,
ob sie noch Salat essen dürfen.
In Deutschland würden sie den Salat
nicht mehr essen.
Oder sie sahen nur noch
tote Fische im Wasser, was los sei.
"Ist das Grundwasser
auch betroffen?"
Solche Katastrophen sind eigentlich
journalistische Highlights.
Manchmal waren wir dann die Bösen,
weil wir die Behörden
damit indirekt angriffen.
* Intromusik *
Guten Abend, liebe Zuschauer.
Eigentlich hätten wir heute etwas
trockene Themen in der Sendung.
Man muss den Leuten
manchmal auch etwas Lustiges
oder Unerwartetes bieten.
Give them the unexpected.
Wie gesagt mussten wir über
viele negative Sachen berichten.
Über Unglücke und allerlei.
Das tut den Leuten
auf die Dauer nicht gut.
Neben den Sorgen
rund um Krankheiten,
Chemie- und Nuklearkatastrophen
versetzte eine Serie von Kindermorden
die Schweiz in Angst und Schrecken.
Ich wuchs zu der Zeit auf,
als viele Kinder verschwanden.
Speziell auch Mädchen
in der Schweiz.
Das war wirklich etwas ...
Ich bekomme jetzt noch Gänsehaut.
Ich weiss noch,
diese Vermisstmeldungen,
die damals auch im Fernsehen kamen,
wenn wieder eines verschwunden war.
Niemand wusste, wie wo was.
Das war etwas, das mich als Kind
wahnsinnig verängstigte.
* Unheimliche, tickende Klänge *
Bei so viel Grau im Alltag
schien das Schweizer Fernsehen
nicht mit Tristesse geizen zu wollen
und lancierte eine TV-Serie,
die bereits im Sendesignet
wenig Hoffnung
auf Lust und Laune versprach.
Die Kritik
kam meist aus einer Ecke.
Der "Blick" machte die Serie
jedes Mal runter und verriss sie.
Die trieben die Macher
auf Fernsehseite quasi vor sich her,
bis es am Ende Nacktszenen gab
und mit Gunter Sachs
etwas Glamour in diese Serie kam.
Es war eine Symbiose derer, die
reklamierten, und des Fernsehens.
Beide waren aufeinander angewiesen.
Wenn es viele Zuschauer gab,
schrieb auch der "Blick" darüber
und andere Medien,
und so gab es noch mehr Zuschauer.
So schaukelte sich das hoch.
Nach 40 Folgen
und der damals aufwühlenden Tatsache,
dass sich Männer
öffentlich küssen können,
platzte dem Programmdirektor
der Kragen
und das "Motel" in Egerkingen
verschwand wieder
von der Fernseh-Landkarte.
* Dumpfer Knall *
(Vetsch) Der Mauerfall bestimmte
das Lebensgefühl dieser Zeit.
Wenn ich mich zurückerinnere,
war es eine Zeit,
die geprägt war vom Aufbruch.
Man kam zusammen,
schaute gemeinsam in die Zukunft.
Ich habe es als eine
sehr positive Zeit empfunden.
Was damals auch ein Thema war,
schon vorher, war tatsächlich,
dass man schon sehr viele
Umweltprobleme benannte.
Lustigerweise
habe ich v.a. in Erinnerung,
dass man sie auch löste.
Z.B. das Ozonloch.
Man verbot dann einfach
all diese "bösen" Spraydosen.
In diesem Geist
bin ich aufgewachsen.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
es stehen grosse Probleme an,
aber wir alle zusammen sind fähig,
sie zu lösen.
(Mann) Lucerne, this is Houston,
go ahead with your call.
Bonjour, Monsieur Nicollier,
c'est Adolf Ogi.
Grüss Gott, Freude herrscht.
Wir sind Astronaut.
Anfang der 90er-Jahre
telefonierte Bundesrat Adolf Ogi
ins Weltall, wo Claude Nicollier
als erster Schweizer Raumfahrer
Geschichte schrieb.
Es war dieser eine Augenblick,
als das Fliegen im Spaceshuttle
einfacher war als das korrekte
Setzen eines Nameneinblenders
in der Fernsehregie.
Vielen Dank für Ihre grosse Arbeit.
Ich sehe das Schweizer Kreuz
und Matterhorn.
Nach 40 Jahren Einsamkeit
erhielt das Schweizer Fernsehen
private Konkurrenz im eigenen Land.
Die Liberalisierung
begann schon etwas früher.
Zuerst das Lokalradio.
Dann kamen die Fernsehsender,
es gab plötzlich Privatfernsehen.
Das Schweizer Fernsehen
stellte sich recht früh
auf die ausländische Konkurrenz ein.
Irgendwann waren es wirklich schwei-
zerische Privatkanäle, TV3 z.B.
Tele 24,
oder als RTL, ProSieben usw.
alle um 19 Uhr
mit Nachrichtensendungen ankamen.
Die Konkurrenz
hat dem Fernsehen gutgetan.
Es war auch
eine zusätzliche Konkurrenz
um die Gunst der Zuschauer/-innen.
Man kann sagen, dass die Konkurrenz
uns angespornt und belebt hat.
Wir wollten diejenigen sein,
die es zuerst hatten
und zuerst vor Ort waren,
die live berichteten.
Es passierte eine Entwicklung,
von der ich glaube,
dass sie das Fernsehen
resistent gemacht hat
gegenüber anderen Einflüssen.
Herzlich willkommen.
Die 90er-Jahre ...
waren eine gute Zeit.
Man war sehr mutig
im Schweizer Fernsehen.
Wenn ich im Nachhinein schaue,
nicht speziell wir,
aber z.B. Kurt Aeschbacher.
Was die alles durchgaben
in diesen Sendungen,
darüber staune ich wirklich.
Wir dachten,
wir machen es lieber lustig
und gehen locker mit dem Pariser um
und lassen sie mit farbigen Ballons
vom Studiohimmel heruntersegeln.
Es gab immer wieder Sendungen,
die provozierten.
Im Nachhinein ist es toll.
Wenn man etwa an "Ventil"
von Frank Baumann denkt:
Die Leute gingen an die Decke.
Sie sagten: "Das gibt's ja nicht!"
Das zeigt:
Wenn man an die Grenzen geht,
ist es für die einen schon zu viel.
Die anderen sagen,
man solle genau so weitermachen.
Als Nächstes haben wir Frau Meier.
Guten Abend, hier spricht
Brigitte Meier aus Elgg.
Müssen Sie schreien?
Können Sie es auch leiser versuchen?
Okay, ich versuche es.
Wenn Sie nur Pieps machen ...
- Pieps.
Dann habe ich Sie direkt im Ohr.
Zu meiner Zeit war der legendäre
Peter Schellenberg Fernsehdirektor.
Er sagte, ich soll einfach machen.
Die Leute unterhalten.
Ich habe die Schuhe an,
wie sich das gehört,
das habe ich beim Arzt gelernt.
Ich werde jetzt also versuchen,
die Narkose auf mich zu nehmen
und dann weiter zu moderieren.
Genau so,
wie das Herr Stutz gemacht hat.
Darf ich Sie bitten?
Geht's?
- Ja.
Sie sehen,
ich bin schon etwas ... weg.
Man wusste genau,
was die Leute wollen und was nicht.
Ja, nein, eben,
stell dir vor, das Konzept ...
Ich stelle mir vor,
wenn heute jemand kommen würde
und dem Gremium sein neues Konzept
vorstellen würde -
und das wäre Publikumsbeschimpfung.
Leute rufen mich an und ich mache
diese Leute so richtig runter,
nach allen Regeln der Kunst.
Wie gross ist die Chance, dass das
Gremium sagt: "Wir glauben an dich"?
(Mann) Es ist schade, dass
das Fernsehen einfach alles macht,
was Geld bringt.
- Ja, das ist so.
Schauen Sie mal unser Dekor an!
Die haben ja kein Geld!
Was muss ich hier machen?
Geh mal runter mit der Kamera,
film mal dort hinten.
Schauen Sie sich das mal an.
Kabel! Es hat nicht mal eine Wand.
So muss ich arbeiten!
Wir reichten ein Konzept ein,
auf dem stand,
dass wir das Publikum
gerne ernst nehmen
und Fragen beantworten würden,
und zwar live.
Man kann anrufen, eine Frage stellen
und sie wird live beantwortet.
Das ist das,
was wir eingereicht haben.
* Ächzen *
Ist es ist bequem?
Es war etwas komisch am Anfang.
Das war die Zeit,
in der man noch keine Angst
vor einem Shitstorm haben musste.
Bei unserer ersten Sendung "Oops"
gab es Zuschauerfeedback,
und die kamen per Fax.
Sie hat uns
vier leidvolle Seiten gefaxt.
Mehr muss man nicht wissen, um sich
diese Zeit vorstellen zu können.
Aktiver Austausch per Fax.
Wir profitierten sehr davon,
denn es ist sehr schwierig,
mit einem Faxgerät
einen Shitstorm zu lancieren.
Im Nachhinein weiss ich nicht,
ob wir so unter Ausschluss
der Öffentlichkeit sendeten,
dass es gar niemand gesehen hat.
Auch das ist möglich.
Auch die Chefinnen und Chefs
hatten vielleicht anderes zu tun,
als uns immer
auf die Finger zu schauen.
Das Schweizer Fernsehen hatte
auf die neue Konkurrenzsituation
und auf die Bedürfnisse
eines jüngeren Publikums reagiert.
Ab September 1997
war das Programm auf zwei Kanälen,
damals SF 1 und SF 2, zu empfangen.
... auf SF 2.
Ich weiss,
dass ich insofern involviert war,
als dass die Werbeabteilung
alle Moderatoren,
die ein wenig bekannt waren,
anfragte,
ob sie ihre Kinder nicht für eine
Plakatkampagne brauchen dürften,
um dieses SF 2,
wie es damals hiess, zu lancieren.
Also so:
"Mein Vater macht 'Schweiz aktuell',
aber ich schaue
eine tolle Serie auf SF 2."
So machten sie diese Kampagne mit
Kindern von prominenten TV-Figuren,
als SF 2 als junger Sender startete.
Aber an einen besonderen Inhalt
oder Knall beim Start von SF 2
kann ich mich jetzt
ehrlich gesagt nicht erinnern.
Meine erste Sendung war historisch.
Nicht wegen mir,
sondern weil am Tag vorher
Lady Di im Tunnel in Paris
tödlich verunglückte.
So eine Aufregung für mich
bei der ersten Sendung -
und es interessierte
keinen Menschen.
* Gefühlvoller Popsong: "Candle
in the Wind" von Elton John *
# Your footsteps will always fall
here, along Englands greenest hills.
# Your candle's burnt out
long before your legend ever will.
Das bewegte und berührte die Massen.
Das kann Fernsehen:
Emotionen wecken.
Wenn Elton John
dann noch beginnt zu singen -
spätestens dann fliessen die Tränen.
Das sind die grossen Fernsehmomente:
die, die Menschen berühren.
* Knall *
* Unheimliche Musik *
* Schwer verständlicher Funkspruch *
Ich werde 9/11 nie vergessen. Klar.
Ich sass im Büro,
als ein Kollege kam und sagte,
dass ein Flugzeug ins
World Trade Center geflogen sei.
Ich rannte hinaus
und sah auf dem Bildschirm
gerade das zweite Flugzeug kommen.
(Mann) Jesus!
Ich kam von der Schule nach Hause
und es war mucksmäuschenstill
und der Fernseher lief.
Ich sah, wie meine Eltern
in den Fernseher schauten.
Ich schaute auch
und sah diese Bilder.
Ich fragte mich, was das ist.
Ist es ein Spielfilm,
sind das Nachrichten?
Ich brauchte einen Moment, bis
ich kapierte, was genau passiert.
Das war ein riesiger Schockmoment.
Das war das erste Mal,
dass ich einen Terroranschlag
im Moment sozusagen miterlebte.
Kein Herbst so trüb
wie der erste des neuen Jahrtausends.
9/11, Amoklauf in Zug, Gotthard-
Inferno, Swissair-Grounding.
Innert weniger Wochen schien
die Welt aus den Fugen geraten.
Guten Abend, Schweiz,
grüezi zu "Schweiz aktuell".
Die ganze Sendung wird den Wirren
um die Swissair gewidmet sein.
Live aus dem Unique-Gebäude
vom Zurich Airport.
Wenn es so schlimm ist
wie eben 9/11 oder solche Sachen,
dann hat man indirekt ein
gemeinsames Erlebnis übers Fernsehen
und gemeinsamen Gesprächsstoff.
Dieses gemeinsame Anteilnehmen
an einschneidenden Ereignissen,
wie es der Amoklauf in Zug
mit 15 Todesopfern
und zehn Verletzten einer war,
wie es das Inferno
im Gotthardtunnel darstellte
oder sich im Grounding der Swissair
abspielte,
zeigte einmal mehr auf,
welch magnetische Wirkung
das Medium Fernsehen
auf das Publikum ausüben kann.
* Tragende Klänge *
Verlässlichkeit und Glaubwürdigkeit,
aber auch die angemessene Tonalität
in der Schilderung des Geschehenen
sind die Trümpfe
des Schweizer Fernsehens,
die das Publikum bis heute schätzt.
* Schriller Einwählton *
Übrigens - heute würde man
Fun Fact dazu sagen:
Im Jahr 2001 waren wir alle
noch die meiste Zeit offline.
Nur knapp 30 % der Bevölkerung
in der Schweiz
nutzten punktuell das Internet.
Wer sich an dieses Geräusch
erinnert, weiss, weshalb.
* Fiepen, Rauschen *
Videos online anzuschauen
war richtig mühsam.
Die meisten nutzen das Internet
in erster Linie
zum Versenden von E-Mails.
Ui, 156 Seiten.
Am Anfang hätte man übers Internet
nicht Fernsehen schauen können,
die Daten wären viel zu schwer
für die Verbindungen gewesen.
Die Infrastruktur, die für
die Fernsehsignale geschaffen wurde,
machte eine datenintensive
Nutzung des Internets
in seiner heutigen Form erst möglich.
Wir versuchten jedes Jahr zu sehen,
wie schnell diese Entwicklung geht.
Wir wussten:
Je mehr es Richtung Internet geht,
desto weniger
wird klassisch ferngesehen,
desto stärker müssen wir
unsere Internetplattform ausbauen.
Wenn wir wollen, dass eine
"Tagesschau" weiterhin genutzt wird.
Einige Leute schauen sie
dann nicht mehr um 19.30 Uhr,
sondern auf anderen Plattformen.
Es ging darum, unsere Inhalte
auf den Kanälen auszuspielen,
die die Menschen heute nutzen.
Zur Erinnerung:
2005 wurde dieses Video als erstes
überhaupt auf YouTube hochgeladen.
Wir stellten fest,
dass wir eine Strategie brauchen,
die der Hausstrategie entspricht.
Wir müssen die Mittel und
den Aufwand effizienter einsetzen.
So entstand die Internetstrategie.
Das letzte Mal wurde es totgesagt
mit der digitalen Disruption.
Man hatte das Gefühl,
dass das Fernsehen vorbei sei
und die Zuschauerzahlen abnehmen
und nur noch die Alten
schauen würden. Teils stimmt das.
Aber das Fernsehen als Bildmedium,
mit der Stärke, die ein Bild hat,
ist das einzige Medium,
das direkt
Emotionen transportieren kann,
oder eben schöne, eindrückliche,
auch schockierende Bilder.
Das ist die Kraft des Fernsehens.
Ich glaube,
diese wird auch im Zeitalter
der digitalen Entwicklungen
bestehen bleiben.
Das waren die Jahre,
als Facebook gegründet wurde,
Alex Frei an der EURO
einen Gegenspieler anspuckte,
Schweine- und Vogelgrippe
auftauchten,
Saddam Hussein gefasst
und getötet wurde
und Madonna und Britney Spears
sich auf der Bühne
zur Empörung vieler küssten.
20 Jahre nach dem Männerkuss
in "Motel".
Und heute?
Was ist geblieben
von diesem wundersamen Kasten,
dank dem die Familien vor 70 Jahren
die Welt von zu Hause aus
entdecken konnten?
Das Fernsehen
wurde bereits totgesagt,
als ich merkte,
dass es immer noch da ist
und man immer noch Fernsehen schaut.
Herzlich willkommen
auf meinem Youtube-Channel.
Tama Vakeesan ist 2017 eine der
Antworten des Schweizer Fernsehens
auf die Frage, wie das junge Publikum
zu erreichen sei.
Die Überlegung war, was ich als Host
in meinem Fall erzählen würde.
Es war das Kulturteam,
deshalb war für mich klar,
dass ich vom Leben zwischen
zwei Kulturen erzählen möchte.
Ich habe einen Blickwinkel, den
die Schweizer/-innen nicht kennen.
Wie ist es,
als Tamilin hier aufzuwachsen?
Wie ist es, Freunde
mit Migrationshintergrund zu haben?
Welchen Blickwinkel haben sie?
(Wappler) Wir wollen
ein Medienhaus für alle sein.
Die Menschen, die in der Schweiz
leben, haben sich verändert.
Wir möchten integrativ sein.
Ich glaube, dass das Fernsehen eine
sehr hohe integrative Kraft hat.
Wir wollen den Leuten,
die Schweizerdeutsch reden
und hier aufgewachsen sind,
die vielleicht
eine andere Hautfarbe haben, zeigen,
dass sie genauso gut bei uns
im Programm vorkommen können
wie auch sonst in der Gesellschaft.
Ich habe nie
dunkelhäutige Menschen gesehen,
die eine wichtige Rolle
eingenommen haben.
Entweder wurde über sie berichtet in
Verbindung mit einer Spendenaktion
oder einer tragischen Geschichte.
Aber nie in einer führenden Rolle
als Moderationsperson.
Das habe ich nie gesehen.
Unterbewusst war immer da,
dass jemand wie ich
nicht ins Fernsehen gehört.
Das war für mich logisch:
Das Schweizer Publikum ist nicht
bereit für jemanden wie mich.
Rückblickend erst
kam mir in den Sinn:
Wieso gab es niemanden,
der aussieht wie ich?
Die Authentizität ist wichtig,
man soll das Gefühl haben,
dass man auch vertreten ist.
Ich bin einer von ihnen.
Das ist wichtig.
Da haben wir
in den letzten vier Jahren
einen grossen Schritt gemacht.
Aber ich glaube,
wir sind noch nicht ganz dort,
wie die Menschen in der Schweiz
eigentlich zusammengesetzt sind.
Das Fernsehen
war der erste grosse Influencer,
der die Gedanken von Menschen prägt.
Wenn etwas
als normal dargestellt wird,
wie z.B.
eine dunkelhäutige Moderatorin
oder ein homosexueller Moderator,
wenn das
als selbstverständlich dargestellt
und genügend oft wiederholt wird,
wird es irgendwann
in der Gesellschaft akzeptiert.
* Jubel und Applaus *
Es passierte
aus einem Bauchgefühl heraus.
Zusammenfassend:
Im Finale dieser Tanzsendung
tanzte ich mit meinem Lebenspartner.
Alle anderen im Finale
tanzten mit dem Coach.
Ich organisierte Blumen
und wollte am Schluss
nur Danke sagen,
dass er das im Finale
mit mir mitgemacht hatte.
Daraus wurde dann
sehr intuitiv ein Heiratsantrag.
Ich möchte sehr gerne dein Mann
werden und du meiner.
(Wappler) Ich war sogar im Studio.
Ich glaubte es gar nicht.
Es war so sympathisch
und so spontan,
dass es mich wirklich bewegte.
Es war wirklich eine Markierung
in der Geschichte
des Schweizer Fernsehens,
dass Sven diesen Antrag machte -
das war ein Statement.
Nur schon die Tatsache,
dass man ein normales Leben führt
und den Leuten zeigt, dass wir
Menschen wie du und ich sind.
Es geht um Akzeptanz,
Toleranz und Respekt.
Ich glaube,
diese Form versuche ich zu leben.
Es muss nicht immer alles
in Grossbuchstaben sein.
Man kann es auch etwas subtiler
machen und den Leuten sagen,
dass es nichts Besonderes ist.
Abbilden, was ist,
gehört auf alle Fälle
zu den Aufgaben des Fernsehens.
Das ist etwas, dass man immer wieder
austesten muss - wie immer.
Das ist das Schöne
an der Fernseharbeit,
wenn man in den Medien arbeitet.
Man muss immer wieder aushandeln,
testen, sich selbst infrage stellen,
etwas wagen.
Das alles bedeutet, die Gesellschaft
im Jetzt zu begleiten.
70 Jahre
Schweizer Fernsehgeschichte -
das ist auch jene Geschichte,
die uns lehrt,
dass früher nicht alles besser war
und dass sich vieles zum Besseren
wenden kann, wenn wir wollen.
Und das sind doch gute Aussichten.
Ich glaube, die Wichtigkeit
des Fernsehens liegt darin,
wenn z.B. eine Pandemie oder
ein Krieg in der Ukraine ausbricht -
es wurde sehr stark hervorgehoben,
dass man
eine verlässliche Quelle braucht.
Es wird sich weiter
in die Richtung entwickeln,
dass man sich selbst aussucht,
was man wann schauen möchte.
Es gibt immer wieder Leute,
die behaupten,
dass die Tessiner und die Welschen
kein Fernsehen brauchen -
aber natürlich brauchen wir eines.
Wir sind
eine so fragmentierte Gesellschaft,
in der jeder nur noch das bekommt,
was ihm persönlich am besten passt.
Die Gefahr, dass man vom Leben
der anderen nichts mehr mitbekommt,
ist inzwischen viel realer
als früher.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass das Fernsehen deshalb stirbt.
Ich fände es schön, wenn
das Fernsehen funktionieren würde.
Aber ich glaube, es stirbt
mit den Leuten, die fernsehen, aus.
Man sagt das bei jedem Medium.
Tatsache ist: Es gibt sie alle noch.
Jedes Medium hat seine Rolle.
Ich glaube, es gibt es noch lange.
Wie die Ausspielkanäle im Einzelnen
in 20 oder 30 Jahren aussehen,
ist offen.
Ich glaube, es wird immer noch
das Vollprogramm geben.
Es ist einfach
ein Bedürfnis der Leute.
(Frau) Damit ist das Programm
des Schweizer Fernsehens
für heute beendet, auf Wiedersehen.
* Langgezogener Piepton *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
A. Duttweiler, M. Hoss,